hablamos de salud de directo américa de
france 24 y marinas ardilla nos acompaña
en nuestro estudio marina vamos a hablar
de las terapias con los psicodélicos o
concretamente el uso de la psilocibina
una sustancia que se encuentra en
algunos hongos que se usa para tratar
trastornos psiquiátricos y también
adicciones de qué se trata [__] buenos
dias raúl así es vamos a hablar de estos
tipos de sustancias que pese a estar
realmente estigmatizadas tienen altos
beneficios para la salud como lo
demuestran varios estudios científicos
hablamos en este caso de la sustancia
psicoactiva la psilocibina que más allá
de sus ojos son recreativos este
componente tiene un alto potencial
médico veamos de qué se trata la
psilocibina es una sustancia producida
por unas 200 especies de hongos de forma
natural tiene efectos psicoactivos lo
que produce las siglas y lozina que es
el producto de la metabolización de la
psilocibina en nuestro cuerpo actúa
sobre el sistema nervioso central
modificando estados de conciencia y
conducta sus efectos psicoactivos y
alucinógenos duran entre a 36 horas se
ha usado para tratar la depresión el
alcoholismo la anorexia nerviosa y
algunas adicciones lo que sabemos hasta
el momento es que no genera dependencia
puede producir también náuseas un
aumento de la temperatura la frecuencia
cardíaca activada y también a
experiencias trascendentales episodios
de miedo o pánico delirio pero también
debido a que estos hongos alucinógenos
tienen otros compuestos para hablar de
esto tenemos con nosotros a pablo zuleta
médico y psiquiatra director del área de
consumo y drogas en la universidad de
los andes
buenos días pablo y gracias por estar
con nosotros en france 24 quería
preguntarte cuéntanos qué produce la
psilocibina en nuestro cerebro
bueno muy buenos días muchas gracias por
la invitación la psilocibina es una
sustancia que se conoce como un agonista
serotoninérgico hay varios tipos de
agonistas de protón enérgicos que actúan
en distintas zonas cerebrales la que
termina siendo de mayor impacto para el
caso del ácido sivina y otros
alucinógenos similares son las áreas
occipital es y tienen una integración
bastante compleja a nivel del tálamo en
donde se genera toda la experiencia de
cambios perceptual es en donde
fundamentalmente en la mayoría de los
casos no hay pérdida de la crítica el
individuo tiene en el caso de su uso una
experiencia y una aplicación digamos un
viaje denominado popularmente en donde
surgen una gran cantidad de
modificaciones en las estructuras
perceptual es digamos en los objetos se
alteran y también aparecen otro tipo de
objetos principalmente de tipo visual
y díganme si no no continua ya el día
será una pregunta pero continúe con esta
idea y ya vamos con la otra pregunta que
le quiero hacer
otro elemento que es importante es que
la forma como se almacena la información
como se puede llegar a tener una
evocación de la memoria del episodio de
la del viaje como tal no es muy precisa
tienen algunos aspectos importantes en
cuanto a que la narración forma parte
también de una construcción individual
acepta lo que se experimenta
ahora si pablo lo saludo muy buen día
gracias por estar con nosotros esta
mañana de viernes en directo américa
esta semana se publicó entonces un
estudio en el que señalaban como este
compuesto de los hongos psicodélicos
ayuda entonces alcohólicos a reducir o
dejar de consumir completamente alcohol
en una de las pruebas más rigurosas de
los beneficios de la psilocibina para
las adicciones como el alcoholismo por
ejemplo me pregunto entonces en qué
consiste este tipo de estudios y cómo
actúa la psilocibina en pacientes con
adicciones y que les genera
bueno en principio lo que es importante
señalar es que estos estudios son
novedosos nosotros estamos incursionando
en un tema que no había sido antes
explorado de la manera como actualmente
sucede que es con estudios clínicos
controlados bajo observación si bien
tenemos unos avances importantes tanto
en los aspectos prometedores de la
depresión y de ciertos aspectos
de lo que puede llegar a ser distintas
formas de adicción todavía tenemos mucho
por recorrer qué es lo que sucede en
general lo que sucede es que la
narración que el individuo tiene
posterior a la toma tiene en la mayoría
de los casos una propuesta de carácter
terapéutico es decir una interacción con
un psicoterapeuta que acompaña el no
solamente el momento de la embriaguez en
muchos casos se usan dosis que no tienen
la expectativa de generar las
alucinaciones como tal es el viaje como
tal sino precisamente esa estimulación
pero tonifica de la que estamos hablando
lo que se ha supuesto es que esos
cambios
duras cerebrales van modificando la
producción de serotonina que en muchos
de los casos está vinculado con
distintos tipos de los hallazgos que
tenemos en adicciones tanto como
elementos de carácter depresivo como
conductas de tipo
explosivas o reiterativas con memorias
que tienen que ver con una reactividad
emocional inadecuada y ese tipo de
elementos se van modificando en la
medida que tenga este tipo de estilo y
pablo también sorprende un poco que como
comentabas adiciones de al alcohol que
es una sustancia legal esté tratada y
haya tenido cierto éxito con sustancias
ilegales como la psilocibina cuéntanos
un poco cuáles son los riesgos de que
estas sustancias estén tan
estigmatizadas de que no se estén
estudiando lo suficiente y que no se
estén aplicando su uso médico o
terapéutico
pues bueno ahí tenemos un problema de
carácter histórico digamos desde la
década de los 70 muy asociado a la
declaración de la guerra contra las
drogas un movimiento político que
prohibió la investigación principalmente
en los eeuu sobre este tipo de
medicamentos en este caso se están
usando los fitoterapéuticos
principalmente y que estaban muy
arraigados en ciertos grupos académicos
que estaban avanzando las
investigaciones desde entonces hasta
ahora hasta hace muy poco tiempo no
tuvimos ningún tipo de avance sino un
estancamiento y lo que se dio en general
fue un uso de carácter recreacional de
los ángulos son cosa en sí mismo no
tienen un riesgo importante consumos
problemáticos los hongos como tal es la
psilocibina ese tipo de agonistas perot
energéticos en donde hay otro tipo de
sustancias tienen insumos de tipo
periódico es decir cada cierto tiempo
las personas que tienen interés con este
tipo de enfriar que es lo hacen
mensualmente si acaso uno puede
encontrar con alguna muy baja cuencias
usos semanales pero principalmente son
sus ocasionales porque no generan esa
necesidad o gusto del consumo compulsivo
y frecuente y por lo tanto eso es lo que
nosotros vivimos ante muchos o que la
sociedad en general las distintas
culturas empezaron a usar esa manera
tradicional que originalmente se había
médico se empezó a usar de distintas
formas incluyendo distintas tipos de
consumos
psicoactivos de turismo es decir en
vinculaban la llegada a distintas zonas
a zonas en donde producía los hongos y
se producía al mismo tiempo como
espacios de consumo hoy en día digamos
podemos hablar de los últimos 10 años se
ha avanzado muchísimo en la
investigación una vez que abre la
posibilidad legal para hacer las
investigaciones pero todavía tenemos una
gran cantidad de limitaciones en las
investigaciones que se hacen en
distintos lugares por ejemplo en
colombia nosotros no tenemos
disponibilidad de psilocibina que esté
validada por enlaces
del estado y al mismo tiempo existen
unos usos no muy claros de microdosis a
través de la producción de hongos pero
esos hongos no tienen ningún tipo de
certeza de qué es lo que contienen ni
cuáles son los beneficios que pueden
tener y eso hace es que si bien existe
la posibilidad de tratamiento no
solamente de las adicciones sino también
de la depresión no tenemos posibilidad
de ser investigación y de avanzar en los
usos médicos de las personas que lo
necesitan
-pablo gracias por su tiempo por estar
con nosotros esta mañana de viernes en
directo américa de france 24 un gran
abrazo
bueno muchísimas gracias pablo zuleta
médico y psiquiatra director del área de
consumo de drogas de la universidad de
los andes en colombia marina por
supuesto también gracias a usted por
acompañarnos siempre en temas de salud
pasamos a saludar en nuestra segunda
invitada del día